[Musique]
oui
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre cet
après-midi les travaux de la haute
assemblée avec une audition de pierre
moscovici premier président de la cour
des comptes ancien ministre de françois
hollande également ancien commissaire
européen
pierre moscovici va présenter aux
sénateurs une enquête de la cour des
comptes sur la fraude sociale
je vous laisse écouter son audition et
clément la paire chargé de mission
auprès de la rapporteure générale à
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
elle fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat qui sera consultable
en vidéo à la demande
je rappelle bien entendu que le port du
masque est obligatoire et je remercie
chacune et chacun d'entre vous pour sa
vigilance
la lutte contrôle social est une
préoccupation ancienne et constante de
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
dans un rapport déposé en juillet 2010
est au nom de la mission d'évaluation et
de contrôle de la sécurité sociale
l'amex intitulé lutter contre la fraude
sociale un impératif pour la justice e
pour le juste droit
nos collègues agnès canayer et anne
emery dumas formulé cinq préconisations
je les rappelle connaître et quantifier
l'afro de renforcer les échanges entre
les caisses anticiper les schémas de
fraude faire évoluer le modèle
déclaratives vers un creux cueille
automatisé des données
mais aussi simplifier et unifier les
définitions depuis notre commission a eu
régulièrement à connaître de ces sujets
de fraudes qui ont fait l'objet des
dispositions en pf ss souvent inspirée
des dispositifs existants en matière
fiscale la fraude sociale s'est
cependant à nouveau invité dans le
programme de contrôle de notre
commission à la suite de l'examen en
séance publique du projet de loi portant
mesures d'urgence économique et social
pour certains la seule fraude à
l'immatriculation et l'assurance maladie
représentait alors 14 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire de quoi financer les
mesures gilet jaune sans difficulté
le débat public sur la fraude sociale
est un débat piégé pour les uns la
fraude aux prestations se justifierait
en quelque sorte par l'état de nécessité
des fraudeurs la difficulté de certains
accéder à leurs droits sociaux ou encore
l'ampleur de la fraude aux cotisations
voire de la fraude fiscale pour les
autres la lutte contre la fraude serait
le remède facile aux difficultés de nos
finances publiques que pour des raisons
étranges les pouvoirs publics ne peuvent
se résoudre à activer notre commission
attaché à la notion de juste droit a
mandaté son rapporteur général ici
présents jean marie vanlerenberghe pour
faire la lumière avec une méthode
robuste sur la fraude à
l'immatriculation objet d'un rapport
déposé en juin 2019
dans le même temps le 28 mai 2019 le
gouvernement chargé deux parlementaires
la sénatrice nathalie goulet et la
députée carole grandjean d'une mission
sur la fraude sociale remis en octobre
2019 le rapport au gouvernement conclut
à l'impossibilité de réaliser un chiffre
un chiffre âge de la fraude sociale la
cour des comptes ayant engagé pour sa
part des travaux le président alain
milon a souhaité les reprendre sous la
forme d'une enquête commandée par la
commission
il indique dans son courrier d'octobre
premier président meego l'époque
ce sujet fait l'objet d'un débat public
et qu'il me semble nécessaire de
structurer par des données objectives
produite selon une méthodologie étayé
c'est donc cette enquête que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui si l'on considère
le montant des prestations sociales
servi dans notre pays quelques 800
milliards d'euros sur le champ le plus
large
il est évident que la fraude existe et
qu'elle doit être combattue la question
est de savoir où elle se situe
précisément et comment les priorités
doivent tête hier à chizé monsieur le
premier président vous avez la parole et
je donne ensuite la parole au rapporteur
général puis à nos collègues qui
souhaite vous interroger le premier
président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
merci de m'avoir invité à vous présenter
aujourd'hui l' enquête de la cour sur la
lutte contre les fraudes aux prestations
sociales
c'est vous l'avais dit la première fois
que j'interviens devant votre commission
depuis ma nomination en juin à la tête
de la cour des comptes et j'en suis très
heureux il est vrai que mes fonctions
passées tout comme les premières
auditions en tant que premier président
ou président du haut conseil des
finances publiques
mon plus tôt conduit à dialoguer avec
vos collègues de la commission des
finances
je reviendrai devant vous dans un mois
le 8 octobre prochain pour vous
présenter notre rapport annuel sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale le ralph's ainsi
qu'une communication sur les groupement
hospitalier de territoire effectué là
aussi à la demande votre commission j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire
le commission des finances je vous le
dis aujourd'hui je suis extrêmement
attachée à la mission d'assistance au
parlement que la constitution a confié à
la cour elle est pour moi essentiel et
même prioritaire d'abord il est vrai que
je conserve une sensibilité d'anciens
parlementaires ancien élu local et sami
un clip ensuite veiller à l'équilibré
des relations de la cour avec le
gouvernement d'une part le parlement
d'autre part fait partie de mes
fonctions et je dirais même de mes
devoirs
ce donc assuré mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que j'attacherai à la relation
privilégiée qui nous unit un soin tout
particulier
pendant mon mandat l'anc est que nous
vous présentons aujourd'hui réalisées
sur la saisine de votre commission
m'offrir l'occasion d'incarner pour
notre première rencontre officielle
l'importance de cette mission
d'assistance et de liens étroits qui
unissent notre institution de
représentation nationale
la crise sanitaire nous a conduit à
différer légèrement la transmission de
cette communication mais nous venons pu
vous la faire parvenir dès cette rentrée
je crois que c'est heureux
j'ai présent mes côtés comme vous l'avez
dit notre rapporteur général michèle
pappalardo houle briet président de
chant de maintenu et contre rapporteur
de l'anc est ainsi que jean-pierre viola
président de section
accompagné de sébastien d'orliac qui en
sont les rapporteurs notre rapport fait
suite plusieurs productions de la cour
relatives aux fraudes sociales
d'abord dans le cadre de notre mission
de certification des comptes du régime
général la sécurité sociale nous
examinons chaque année la portée des
dispositifs mise en oeuvre par les
branches pour réduire les risques de
fraude en 2019
nous avons aussi établi des rapports sur
les fraudes aux prestations de retraite
d'assurance maladie et des branches
famille
la cour a par ailleurs remis au premier
ministre l'an dernier sa demande d'une
communication consacrée à la fraude aux
prélèvements obligatoires qui couvrait
bien entendu et prélèvements sociaux
mission qui était présidée par mon
prédécesseur lui-même
l'enquète que vous nous avez demandé et
que je vous présente aujourd'hui vise à
fournir une vision d'ensemble des
actions engagées pour lutter contre les
différents types de fraudes aux
prestations sociales et les résultats
obtenus à ce titre le champ de cette
enquête est très large puisqu'il couvre
l'ensemble des prestations versées par
les branches prestations du régime
général maladie accidents du travail
maladies professionnelles famille et
vieillesse et sur plusieurs points
déterminants d'appréciation pour
l'emploi et agirc arrco ce champ
représente au total il faut le dire plus
du cinquième du produit intérieur brut
de 2019 avant de vous présenter nos
conclusions
je tient d'emblée à souligner un point
qui à mes yeux est capitale tchèque la
cour a pour mission d'apporter les
informations il a dit objective et c'est
ce à quoi nous nous sommes
attaché dans le cadre de cette enquête
ici comme toujours notre approche est
celle de magistrats financiers
c'est celle de l'examen des moyens
engagés celle des résultats obtenus
c'est de l'analyse de la gestion celle
de l'investigation sur pièces et sur
place
ce qu'il n'est pas possible de chiffrer
de manière suffisamment fiable et bien
nous le chiffre on pas notre rapport
notre priorité c'est l'examen des faits
c'est la robustesse des conclusions
c'est la formulation recommandations
opérationnelles et utile en toute
objectivité en toute indépendance
loin de l'esprit polémique qui
caractérise souvent la manière dont ce
sujet le sujet de des fraudes aux
prestations sociales est abordée j'y
reviendrai mais vous avez vous dit vous
même monsieur présent que ces terres
débat piégé il l'est assurément un débat
caricatural il l'est parfois et la cour
est là pour tenter d'apporter sa
contribution à votre commission comme
vous l'avez dit sur des faits dûment tu
étais y est ni plus ni moins
lorsqu'elle est avéré la fraude aux
prestations sociales créées de dommages
pas seulement préjudiciable aux
multinationales
le premier est bien sûr financier mais
le second est pour moi plus grave encore
c'est celui de l'atteinte au pacte
républicain qui font depuis 1945 la
sécurité sociale
je suis l'atteinte aux décisions du
législateur et au jet confiance
qu'accorde aux citoyens à notre système
de protection sociale nous sommes donc
attachés de notre rapport à dresser le
bilan de l'ensemble des actions
déployées pour prévenir détecter mesurer
réprimées in fine et réparer les
conséquences financières des pros
prestations sociales
nous l'avons fait en restituant la lutte
contre la fraude dans un cadre dice
global c'est celui des irrégularités
tous ordres qui affecte l'attribution le
calcul ou le versement des prestations
et qui se traduisent par un excellent
versement donc des indus lorsque les
irrégularités ont un caractère
volontaire
c'est une nuance importante elles
constituent des fraudes
dans le cas contraire elles sont simples
erreurs
il est parfois difficile j'en convient
de distinguer d'erreurs et la fraude
d'autant qu'elles emportent des effets
financiers en grande partie identique
pour les finances publiques
l'enjeu primordial et donc pour nous
celui du paiement à bon droit des
prestations c'est de leurs attributions
et versement à la personne qui remplit
les conditions et pour un montant exact
je reviens maintenant au contenu
lui-même du rapport et peut être résumée
en deux constats et de série de
recommandations les constats sont les
suivants premièrement les résultats
obtenus dans la lutte contre les fraudes
aux prestations s'améliorent
année après année notamment grâce à des
ressources humaines
globalement préservée il ya des moyens
d'investigation qui s'étendent tout en
restant un complet est important de
commencer par là parce qu'il n'y a pas
que des mauvaises nouvelles
deuxièmement ces progrès incontestables
sont pourtant trop lent ou regard des
enjeux les actions engagées restent très
en deçà des risques de fraude en sachant
que le montant de la fraude n'est pas
estimé par les organismes sociaux sauf
exception c'est pourquoi un changement
d'échelle nous paraît indispensable
nos recommandations visent donc d'une
part et c'est l'enjeu primordial à tarir
à la source les possibilités systémique
de fraude que permet un système
déclaratif trop ouvert et d'autre part
pour lutter plus efficacement contre les
fraudes que ce resserrement du système
déclaratif ne permettrait pas d'éviter à
renforcer à la fois les contrôles visant
les détecter et les conséquences
financières de leur découverte pour
leurs auteurs comment sont si vous le
voulez bien par notre premier constat
c'est une progression des résultats
financiers la lutte contre les fraudes
aux prestations sociales qui traduit une
professionnalisation croissante
les chiffres sont très parlants en 2019
les organismes sociaux ont détecté un
milliard de préjudice subi et
d'activités dans le cadre de la lutte
contre les fraudes en 2019 la branche
famille a identifié 324 millions de
préjudice subi au titre des fraudes soit
tout de même presque quatre fois plus
qu'en 2010 l'assurance maladie
c'est 287 millions d'euros de préjudices
subis éviter au titre de fraude et de
fautes soit presque deux fois plus qu'en
2010 la vieillesse c'est 160 millions
d'euros soit deux fois plus qu'en 2013
pour l'emploi 212 me andré jus 10 subie
éviter c'est à dire cinq fois plus qu'en
2010 vous aurez compris entendre ces
chiffres et les lire que les préjudices
identifié porte sur des périmètres non
identiques non homogène ce qui renvoie à
mon propos liminaires sur les la zone
grise entre fraude et erreurs
les fraudes détectées se concentre sur
certains types de prestations d'auteur
situation pour la branche famille se
sont principalement le rsa l'apprennent
d'activité les aides au logement qui
font l'objet de fraudes à lui seul le
rsa représenté près d'une faute
qualifiée sur deux 46%
l'omission les fausses déclarations de
ressources constitue le premier mode
opératoire des fraudes détectées par les
4 69% 2019 pour l'assurance maladie ce
sont les professionnels et
établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux qui concentre une part
prépondérante des montants de préjudices
subis éviter ces 80% 2019
ce qui est ici en cause sont des
facturations d'actes médicaux et
paramédicaux de séjour en établissement
de santé de prestations et de biens de
son effectif ainsi que des
surfacturations pour la branche
vieillesse les prestations du minimum
vieillesse soumise à des conditions de
ressources et de riz dans stahl en
france ont été à l'origine de près de 3
fraude sur quatre détectées en 2010
enfin pour pôle emploi
les reprises activités non déclarées
représente chaque année depuis 2015 plus
de 70 % du nombre d'affaires
frauduleuses les contrôles menés pour
détecter les fraudes avérées ou
présumées bénéficient maintenant de
ressources notables et des structures
spécialisées
nous estimons ainsi que près de 4000
agents en équivalent temps plein étaient
directement affectées contre les fraudes
en 2019 principalement dans les caf les
cpam et le service médical de
l'assurance maladie
cet ordre de grandeur est maintenant
relativement stable au cours des
dernières années alors que le nombre
global de collaborateurs des organismes
sociaux lui de son côté a plutôt eu
tendance à diminuer
les effectifs affectés la relation de
contrôles pour détecter les fraudes ont
plutôt donc été préservée dans un
contexte moins fabre la sélection des
contrôles effectués à postériori
bénéficier aussi d'amélioration continue
grâce au signalement interne des
services ou signalements de partenaires
administratifs ou requêtage de leurs
propres données de plus en plus fonction
d'une analyse prédictive du risque
d'anomalies c'est ce qu'on appelle data
mining est les organes sociaux detec
fréquemment des irrégularités qui pour
certaines pas tout correspondent à des
fraudes en 2019 les cpm ont en moyenne
détecter des préjudices et leur
détriment
lors de trois contrôles sur quatre dans
près de deux sur trois les contrôles sur
place qui effectue les caf qui sont les
contrôler plus poussée les conduisent à
modifier la situation des allocataires
en constatant des indus et dans une
moindre mesure des rappels sur
prestation outre un ciblage plus
efficient des contrôles les moyens
d'investigation des initiations été
étendue en effet été dotés de
prérogatives similaire à celle d'
administration fiscale pour vérifier
l'exactitude des informations déclarées
par et bissière de prestations ils
peuvent donc pour réaliser leur contrôle
consulter un grand nombre d'informations
détenues par leurs homologues les
homologues d administration de l'état ou
d'autres tiers comme les établissements
bancaires nous constatons pourtant que
de nombreuses insuffisances demeure dans
la mutualisation des informations entre
cagnes sociaux et avec les
administrations de l'état au détriment
du contrôle de la composition et les
ressources des foyers de la résidence en
france nous constatons aussi que
contrairement aux organismes de sécurité
sociale pour l'emploi n'est toujours pas
doté les droits de communication de
tiers cette différence de traitement n'a
pour nous aucune forme de justification
davantage détecter les fraudes et photos
prestations sociales sont également
davantage sanctionné les caisses de
sécurité sociale comme pôle emploi
bénéficient d'une large palette
d'instruments pour réprimer les fraudes
elle utilise principalement les
sanctions administratives qui consiste
en des avertissements des pénalités
financières décidées par les directeurs
et sociaux
depuis que pôle emploi s'est vu
transférer ce pouvoir au 1er janvier
le nombre de sanctions c'est à signaler
a augmenté de près de 70% par rapport
aux années précédentes
mais toutes les fraudes détectées
qualifié comme tel par la caisse
d'assurance maladie les caisses de
retraite les direction de pôle emploi ne
sont pas sanctionnés même sous la faute
la forme d'un avertissement pour
l'avenir donc voilà pour ce premier
constat qui montre tout de même une
amélioration significative qu'il faut
reconnaître et souligner comme tel il
faut donc relativiser les résultats
obtenus contre les fraudes qui sont
moins favorables qu'il n'y paraît ce qui
m'amène à la deuxième partie du rapport
l'impact des actions mises en oeuvre
pour lutter contre les fraudes sur
l'évolution de ces dernières et d'autres
organes étaient n'est pas totalement
démontré depuis 2010 la branche fanny
effectué une enquête annuelle
d'évaluation du paiement à bon droit et
de la fraude pour 2018
cette enquête chiffre est important que
ressortir un montant de fraude estimée à
2,3 milliards d'euros ce qui
représentait 3 2% que prestations
versées les indus détecter qualifié de
frauduleux par les caf mais représente
donc qu'une très faible part de la
fraude estimée tout juste 13 % 2018 pour
l'assurance maladie et la branche
vieillesse suis dit que nous ne
connaissons pas les chips anglais donne
un poids n'est pas possible d'apprécier
dans quelle mesure les contrôles qui
vise à détecter des fraudes permet de le
réduire
en effet la cnam se refuse à estimer la
fraude aux prestations et la cnav
il ya renoncé ces choix conduisent
malheureusement occulter l'enjeu
financier des fraudes en soi et
comparaisons
en prison au caf de son côté pôle emploi
avait estimé mais sur un champ très
étroit
le montrant des fraudes à 1 % des
prestations versées en 2012 le montant
des préjudices détecté par les contrôles
représentait un peu plus de 20% de ce
montant
je précise qu'à l'issue de l'enquêté de
la cour pour l'emploi s'est engagé à
procéder à une estimation périodique de
la fraude sur un champ désormais plus
étendue que retenir de tout cela c'est
qu'ils estiment ou non le montant des
fraudes les organes sociaux perdre en
tout état de cause des sommes
considérables au titre d' erreur pour
certaines il ya des fraudes qui ont un
caractère définitif ou d'avoir été
détectées et corrigée en 2018
les caf ont versé environ 3 milliards
d'euros de prestations à tort soit
environ 4 5% du montant total
s'agissant de l'assurance-maladie
l'acclament existe estime pour 2019 à 1
milliards le montant des factures et
régla de professionnels et des
établissements de santé qui a eu lieu à
un règlement en tiers payant à ces
derniers mais ce montant ne couvre pas
les séjours dans les établissements de
santé publics et privés non lucratifs et
il est par ailleurs sous-évalué à
plusieurs titres
nous n'avons pas pu chiffrer l'ensemble
des utilités en question et nous
apparaître toutefois certain que les
règlements injustifiée aux
établissements et aux professionnels de
santé sont bien supérieures à un
milliard d'euros je m'en tiens ici aux
facturations irrégulière sans aborder à
ce stade la question des prisons serge
injustifiées les frais de santé en vue
d'assurer qu'ils ne remplissent pas ou
plus les conditions pour bénéficier de
droits à l'assurance maladie si les
organismes sociaux subissent des pertes
élevées au titre de fraudes et
d'irrégularités
c'est parce que les contrôles ne sont
pas suffisamment nombreux au regard des
risques géant fournir quelques exemples
chaque année et dans le meilleur des cas
4 % de quelques 86 milles infirmiers
libéraux facturant des soins à
l'assurance mailly font l'objet de
contrôles plus ou moins poussée 4%
alors que des montants aberrant
d'honoraires de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros sont fréquemment
facturé à l'assurance-maladie tout pas
le vendre certains départements c'est
dire qu'il ya encore une très large
marge de progrès en 2018 un infirmier à
facturer pratiquement 1,3 million
d'euros
autre illustration de la faiblesse des
contrôles chaque année l'assurance
maladie contrôler au plus la facturation
de 0 7 % des séjours en établissements
de santé publics ou privés là aussi
marge de manoeuvre ou le progrès
considérables il est donc et j'en viens
troisième point essentiel de renforcer
l'efficacité lutte contre les fraudes
aux prestations sociales
et c'est l'objet même des
recommandations que nous vous faisons
que nous faisons au delà de vous public
citoyen pouvoirs publics dans notre
rapport
cette action de lutte présente à notre
sens une faiblesse consubstantiel dire
qu'elle consiste à rechercher par des
contrôles a posteriori des irrégularités
dû être empêché a priori dans le cadre
des processus même de gestion des
prestations
dans ces conditions le nombre de
contrôles effectués nécessairement très
insuffisants au regard de l'ampleur des
risques de fraude et plus largement
d'irrégularités aux prestations
selon nous il faut donc engager une
action globale de sécurisation du
versement des prestations sociales et
pour faire court il s'agit de réduire le
périmètre
aujourd'hui partie menthe et étendue des
modes opératoires possible de fraude en
létard hissant à la source le plus
possible comment procéder la cour a
identifié trois chantiers déterminant
premier chantier circonscrire les
usurpations d'identité
ces usurpations constituent les fraudes
les plus manifestes à défaut d'être les
plus coûteuses une sécurisation
élémentaire de consiste à rapprocher
systématiquement et de manière
automatisée les coordonnées bancaires
des bénéficiaires de prestations avec le
fichier des comptes bancaires ou
vers en france le ficoba qui est tenu
par l'administration fiscale
ça fait déjà cinq ans que ce chantier a
été aboutis et ça n'a pas ouvert n'a
toujours pas abouti c'est beaucoup trop
long
il doit donc être rapidement menés à
terme tous les organismes caf cpam
carsat pour l'emploi gercar co msa un
autre croisement automatisé
d'informations aussi vocation à être
mises en oeuvre spécifiquement entre la
cnaf et de dg philippe enfin d'apporter
de garanties élémentaires d'une part sur
le fait que les logements support des
aides au logement existe effectivement
et sont dûment occupés par des
bénéficiaires de ces aides et d'autre
part sur le fait que les bailleurs
privés déclarer au fisc des revenus
fonciers au moins égaux vous aide versée
c'est le moins qu'on peut attendre
il importe aussi de réduire les
possibilités la durée des détournements
de l'utilisation des cartes vitale
l'enjeu essentiel c'est de
dématérialiser la carte d'assurance
maladie et d'en faire un moyen de
consultations des droits dans le système
d'information d'assurance manning et non
plus comme aujourd'hui avec les cartes
vitale le support des droits ça
permettrait de donner un effet immédiat
aux clôtures de droit et d'empêcher
ainsi les prises en charges injustifiée
de dépenses par l'assurance maladie même
après leur clôture
une expérimentation de cette future
icarte est en cours dans la tente du
remplacement des cartes vitale combien
que les régimes d'assurance maladie
achève de mettre fin aux situations de
détention de plusieurs cartes activée
par un même assuré
c'est situation ça paraît anecdotique
mettait tout de même estimé à 152 mille
fin juin 2020 deuxième chantier c'est la
fiabilisation des salaires des
ressources et des situations
professionnelles
à l'heure actuelle les urssaf ne
rapproche pas sauf exception les données
individuelles de salaire prises en
compte pour vers les droits de salariés
retraite de base aux allocations chômage
et aux indemnités journalières avec les
données agrégées de salaire non
détaillées par le salarié qui constitue
l'assiette des cotisations
pourtant les employeurs de leur côté
d'éclat à la fois ces données
individuelles et ses données agrégées
dans leur déclaration sociale nominative
mansieux
cette déconnexion des prestations par
rapport aux cotisations se traduit
principalement par une insuffisance de
cotisation de certains employeurs il
convient que le réseau des urssaf y
mette fin
en rapprochant systématiquement les
données individuelles et données
agrégées l'enjeu financier vous en
doutez tout à fait considérable pour la
branche famille il est nécessaire selon
nous de déployer un nouveau mode de
production de prestations
celui ci ferait reposer l'attribution de
prestations sur les données de revenus
d'activités de remplacement déclarés par
les employeurs et par les organes
sociaux et rassemblés dans un dispositif
ressources mutualisées mise en place
pour permettre le calcul des aides au
logement en fonction des revenus
contemporain ce chantier déjà engagés
pour la prime l'activité la cnav que
voient les tendances 8 vrai ça aux
autres prestations
mais son calendrier reste incertain
il faut lui donner de la visibilité par
ailleurs la cnam des pôles emploi
convocation à utiliser les données du
dispositif ressources mutualisées afin
de détecter plus rapidement et de façon
plus complète les reprises d'activités
qui font suite à un arrêt de travail
honda de chômage et justifie
d'interrompre le versement des
indemnités journalières les allocations
chômage ou encore nous réviser le
montant
enfin troisième chantier et ce n'est pas
le moindre
nous devons gérer de manière plus
rigoureuse les droits et prestations
d'assurance man il ya ici aussi un
double enjeu
d'abord il faut résorber le surnom de
droit ouvert une prise en charge des
frais de santé par l'assurance maladie
par rapport aux assurés qui remplissent
les conditions d'activité de résidence
stable en france pour en bénéficier
devant la commission denquête
l'assemblée nationale sur la fraude aux
prestations sociales
la direction de sécurité sociale a
finalement reconnu l'existence d'un
surnom de droits ouverts qu'elle a
estimé montant plus que significatif est
2,4 millions d'assurés
selon nous ce surnombre des passants
fait 3 millions d'assurés la direction
de la sécurité sociale ayant une
exception trop large des catégories
d'assurés qui ont des droits à
l'assurance maladie
quoi qu'il en soit
les divers assurés ayant des droits
ouverts à tort n'ont pas toujours
conscience de les régulariser leur
situation
une part indéterminé d'entre eux reçoit
les soins pris en charge par l'assurance
maladie
donc je financier tout ça pourrait aussi
être très significatif
quelles sont les causes de ce surnombre
assure m
c'est ici une question sur laquelle nous
avons beaucoup travaillé pour nous je le
dis parce que j'avais évoqué un débat
piégé qui peut être aussi parfois un
débat à utiliser ou un débat biaisé via
insiste il ne s'agit certainement pas de
l'immatriculation en masse à la sécurité
sociale 2 millions d'assurés fictive qui
serait né à l'étranger comme on peut
parfois l'entendre un tel procédé est
juste matériellement impossible nous
rejoignons à cet égard aux propres
conclusions monsieur le rapporteur
général
quant au caractère circonscrit de la
fraude à l'immatriculation la sécurité
fias les assurés nés à l'étranger par
rapport aux autres modes opératoires de
fraude de plus constatons que les
assurances surnombre sont très
majoritairement nés en france et non à
l'étranger
je crois que ce sont des faits qu'il est
quand même important dans le débat
public tel que nous le connaissons de
réaffirmer et de préciser en revanche
nous savons à un fait qui est tout à
fait objectif qu'il que les flux annuel
de radiation de droits à l'assurance
maladie sont nettement inférieurs à ceux
des départs de france à l'étranger
estimée par l'insee des droits une prise
en charge des frais de santé par
l'assurance m'a dit français sont ainsi
maintenus ouverts à tort ou titre
d'assurer qu'ils ont quitté la france
pour nos pays ou qui ne vivent
qu'épisodiquement france le ministère de
la santé et de la cnamgs désormais tirer
les conséquences ce dérèglement est
révisé en profondeur les modalités de
gestion t3 des assurés ensuite j'en
viens au deuxième enjeu qui est tout
aussi déterminant sinon plus
il faut assainir les règlements de
l'assurance maladie aux professionnels
et aux établissements de santé entière
pays je m'explique les contrôles a
posteriori effectué par l'assurance
maladie sur des nombre réduit de facture
ne lui permettre de récupérer qu'une
faible partie des préjudices financiers
qu'elle subit du fait de facteurs non
conformes à l'alimentation aux
prestations aux prescriptions médicales
aux décisions de services médicaux pour
remédier à ces irrégularités nous
recommandons que des contrôles
automatisés de conformité des
facturations au nouveau créatures
tarifaire en vigueur aux décisions des
service médical soit intégrée à la
chaîne informatisé de règlement des
frais de santé qui bloquerait a priori
des règlements non conformes il importe
aussi de développer la prescription
électronique des actes des prestations
les biens de santé l'assurance maladie
les propose actuellement une solution de
type prescription que pour les
transports sanitaires et les peux tu
peux utiliser et donc selon nous
possible non à bien les trois chantiers
je viens d'évoquer d'assécher à la
source
une grande partie des risques de fraude
mais cette action préventive ne pas
suffire el sol faut aussi bien sûr il
intensifier la recherche des fraudes
afin d'exposer leurs auteurs à des
risques accrus de découverte et leur
faire réparer lançons des procès
préjudice financier qu'il commette donc
identification et sanctions sont là pour
compléter la démarche d'anticipation et
de recherche à la source que j'évoquais
tout d'abord les caractéristiques même
des prescriptions vont continuer à
rendre nécessaire un renforcement des
contrôles sur place pour détecter les
irrégularités les plus difficiles après
si je pense ressources procurées par le
travail dissimulé ou la stabilité la
résidence sur le territoire national je
pense aussi à la réalité des actes ou
des biens de santé dont les facturations
l'assurance maladie ne font pas
apparaître de non conformité par rapport
à une règle de droit une prescription
médicale
bien sûr des marges d'efficience
subsiste un emploi des ressources
humaines effectué la réalisation des
contrôles
nous identifions plusieurs dans le
rapport mais doit pas être surestimé les
investigations requiert temps
significatif un changement d'échelle des
masses financières des régularités
détectée ça nous paraît envisageable
inenvisageable plus tôt sans un
renforcement des moyens humains
consacrés à cette tâche
comme je l'évoquais il ya quelques
instants ces contrôles font leur preuve
et donc il ne faut pas mégoter et moyens
qui leur sont affectés les contrôles
doivent aussi s'adapter
qualitativement à l'évolution des
menaces
actuellement les disposer de lutte
contre les fraudes vise essentiellement
des procédés individuel comportant des
modes opératoires
si je veux dire simple les fraudes
sophistiqués ou en bande organisée sont
donc encore peu recherché alors que les
trafics dans ce domaine sur ce qu'on
appelle dark web représente un enjeu
croissant dans une sociaux sont
insuffisamment coordonnées ils sont
insuffisamment innovant dans la proche
des risques de fraude nous pensons à cet
égard que la création d'une unité
spécialisée transversale composé
d'experts dans la répression des
agissements criminels et la
cybercriminalité est un défi non
seulement nationale mais internationale
permettrait de franchir un palier
significatif
beaucoup de progrès restent aussi à
faire sur un autre sujet qui est celui
de la réparation financière et
préjudices détecté il faut d'abord pour
ça constaté la totalité des préjudices
financiers subis au titre de frauder et
les recouvrer plus efficacement à
l'heure actuelle les systèmes
d'information d'assurance maladie et
ceux des branches famille permettent de
récupérer les indus frauduleux non pas
sur les cinq années applicable à ces
ennuis d'après les textes mais
uniquement sur les deux années qui
s'applique au sein d'union frauduleux
une partie des 1 du lit à des fraudes
détectées ne sont donc ni chiffré ni mis
en recouvrement
l'obsolescence des systèmes
d'information l'assurance maladie était
branche vieillesse affecte aussi
l'efficacité du recouvrement des indus
7e d'information doivent absolument être
mis à niveau
il faut aussi que les dispositions
législatives du code de sécurité sociale
qui donne en principe depuis 2010
l'assurance maladie des possibiltés
d'extrapoler les indus détecté sur une
facture passe enfin faire l'objet de
mesures réglementaires d'application
ces extrapolations d'un dut devrait
également couvrir les actes médicaux et
para médicaux les séjours en talisman de
santé toutes ces évolutions sont
essentiels pour permettre à l'assurance
m'a dit de rentrer dans ses fonds quand
des fraudes et d'autres irrégularités
sont commises en série comme c'est
maintenant souvent le cas enfin
l'arsenal des sanctions à disposition
des organismes sociaux doivent être
davantage mobilisés aujourd'hui une
assurance m'a dit des conventions
rarement les professionnels de santé
même en cas de fraude identifiée répéter
le code de la sécurité sociale prévoit
depuis 2007 une procédure d'urgence pour
interrompre les agissements les plus
graves mais les mesures réglementaires
d'application n'ont pas été adoptés là
encore elle doit donc être prise
absolument sans tarder nous recommande
d'instaurer en plus teinté
conventionnement d'office d'une durée
variable en fonction la gravité des
faits des professions de santé
sanctionné à deux reprises par la voie
pénale ou administrative au titre de
fraude qualifiés ayant épuisé les voies
de recours
il est essentiel de mettre un terme aux
surfacturations répétait à l'assurance
maladie
j'en ai terminé monsieur le président
monsieur rapportant général monsieur le
sénateur messieurs mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs avec les présentations des
résultats de notre enquête rappelle très
brièvement les principaux messages
d'abord lutter plus efficacement contre
les fraudes aux prestations sociales
comportent trois prérequis estimé dans
tous les cas le montant de la fraude
sécuriser en amont le versement des
prestations sociales avec les trois
chantiers clés de le paix précédemment
renforcer en aval les contrôles et
permettre aux organes sociaux de
récupérer le plus possible les
préjudices financiers subis du fait des
fraudes ensuite un changement d'échelle
en termes de moyens est indispensable un
poids moyens technologiques et moyens
humains notre rapport fournit une liste
de quinze recommandations systémique et
opérationnelles qui dessine un programme
oui de réforme des modalités de gestion
des droits et prestations sociales
la mise en oeuvre de ces recommandations
permettrait de réduire à notre sens très
sensiblement la fraude et les
irrégularités aux prestations sociales
et ainsi économiser plusieurs milliards
nous ne donnons pas d'estimation globale
ou spectaculaires comme le font d'autres
mais aussi dans notre for intérieur nous
pensons qu'elles vont un peu parfois
gonflé sans ce nom du ballon et une
volonté politique forte et la
indispensable pour engager mener à bien
ces chantiers en affirmant une priorité
claire en faveur du droit du paiement un
bon droit à des prestations sociales
voilà je crois que la cour dans ce
rapport qui ne vise pas le spectaculaire
mais qui débouchent sur des
recommandations très concrètes est dans
son rôle
éviter de piéger ce débat éviter de
manipuler mais tentez de l'éclairer
c'est pour ça que nous sommes parce
qu'on est heureux et fier de présenter
ce rapport devant votre commission je
vous remercie de votre attention pardon
j'ai été un peu long mais le rapport est
riche et je me tiens à votre disposition
avec les membres de la cour qui
m'entourent qui eux on travaillait
précisément sur le rapport depuis
l'origine pour répondre à vos
interrogations
à vos questions et donc je répondrai à
ce que je sais et je passerai la parole
sinon probablement opportun monsieur
viola ou votre rapporteur raoul briet
pour l'essentiel merci merci monsieur le
président avant d'ouvrir un débat non
piégée celui là je voudrais au nom de
mes collègues souhaité la bienvenue à
daniel garcia qu'est les nouvelles élus
des bouches-du-rhône au remplacement de
notre collègue michel amiel mai avenue
madame la parole au rapporteur général
jean-marie merci monsieur le président
merci rené paul sur le premier président
je vous n'avez pas été trop long c'est
un sujet essentiel vous l'avez souligné
176 pages ce rapport et ça ne mérite
effectivement c'est complexe et je
remercie donc la cour des comptes pour
ces travaux qui ont le mérite de donner
des bases solides sur un sujet qui
évidemment prête à polémique vous l'avez
rappelé à des fantasmes aussi alors là
votre rapport dresse un panorama très
large qui montre bien les enjeux
multiples je crois que vous avez apporté
de nombreuses pistes intéressantes pour
renforcer la lutte contre la fraude
trois chantiers je crois très clair je
pense que ça nous l'avons tous noté
notre commission bien sûr pourra s'en
inspirer tentant en matière législative
et on aura l'occasion peut-être de le
faire rapidement dans le prochain dans
la prochaine loi de finance de sécurité
sociale et pour aussi les futurs travaux
de contrôle notamment ceux de l'amex et
nous nous évidemment nous suivrons vos
recommandations
je regrette toutefois que vous n'ayez
pas essayer de procéder vous même un
chiffrage des différents types de fautes
j'ai bien entendu les raisons pour
lesquelles vous avez vous n'avez pas
vous n'êtes pas engager jusque là mais
qu'en conséquence la hiérarchisation des
actions à mener n'apparaissent qu'en
creux dans votre rapport
je rappelle elle vous l'avez souligné
d'ailleurs vous même que j'en ai fait
l'expérience avec la fraude à
l'immatriculation des personnes qui
étaient nés à l'étranger lancer des
chiffres de 14 milliards
rené-paul savary l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure nous conclusion ces 140 millions
c'est 100 fois moins 100 fois moins donc
ça donne lieu à des fantasmes à des
utilisations d'ailleurs polémiques
politiques abusives bien sûr et je pense
que la méthode que nous avions utilisé
par sondage sur les différends sur les
organismes prestataires étaient
parfaitement utilisable me semble utile
dans en tout je dirais sécurité en
utilisant les méthodes éprouvées du
sondage par quotas sur des populations
quand même qu'on peu échantillonnée
assez facilement alors dans l'immédiat
j'aurais quand même quelques questions à
vous poser sur certains points du
rapport donc à l'exception de la cnaf
vous souligner les carences des
différents organismes en matière
justement destination de la fraude
or je vous rejoins complètement pour
dire que l'évaluation du préjudice est
la base de tout lutte toute lutte contre
la fraude est simplement à partir des
moyens techniques et humains existant
dans quel délai et quel coût les
différents organismes pour est il selon
vous être en mesure de réaliser ces
estimations réalistes en la matière
c'est la première question vous plaidez
vous plaidez aussi pardon à plusieurs
reprises pour renforcer les croisements
des fichiers entre organismes et
administrations
il ya pourtant déjà eu plusieurs
avancées significatives ces dernières
années notamment dans le cadre de la loi
du 23 octobre 2018
pourriez-vous préciser ce qu'il faudrait
développer en détaillant ce qui
nécessiterait de nouvelles dispositions
législatives
est ce qui relève de la simple mise en
oeuvre du droit existant par les
organismes
donc voilà pour la deuxième question
la troisième question pour renforcer la
lutte contre la fraude aux prestations
vous plaidez pour une dématérialisation
renforcer et vous n'avez pas tort
notamment pour ce qui concerne les
cartes vitale et des prestations
associées
mais est ce que vous ne craignez pas
néanmoins que la dématérialisation
puisse engendrer de nouveaux types de
fraudes serait important effectivement
de cadres et
cette dématérialisation et d'autre part
comment éviter que celle-ci ne renforce
pas l'exclusion des personnes les plus
précaires sujets souvent évoquées
notamment pas le défenseur des droits 4e
15e et dernière question
enfin vous plaît des fortement pour un
renforcement des contrôles de régularité
des actes médicaux est effectivement
vous l'avez souligné sont importants les
montants sont très importants dans le
cadre de l'assurance maladie
comment faut-il concilier un tel
renforcement avec l'obligation paiement
dans un délai de sept jours de
l'assurance maladie aux professionnels
je crois que c'est une question aussi
qu'ils méritent effectivement d'avoir
votre éclairage
merci monsieur le président merci donc
des questions précises c'est le premier
président monsieur le rapporteur général
d'abord bien sûr la cour comprends votre
frustration sur le chiffrage pour tout
dire elle est elle même frustré mais
hélas je voulais 17 tradition de
travailler sur des données étayé
chiffres et c'est notre métier on a eu
la même déception sur la fraude fiscale
en général où nous étions refusé à
donner un chiffre
j'étais à l'époque commissaires
européens de l'autre côté de la matière
de mètres de la barrière j'aurais
attendu moi même ce chiffre là mais je
conçois qu'il était difficile à la cour
de le donner comme vous devez comprendre
que là aussi c'est pour discuter
davantage mais notre sentiment c'est que
non la méthode des quotas n'étaient pas
utilisables pour les professionnels sur
les établissements de santé qu'il aurait
fallu constater constitué des
échantillons de plusieurs milliers
d'opérations en examinant les dossiers
médicaux eux mêmes il faudrait le faire
c'est peut-être gérable mais c'est lourd
et c'était pas possible malheureusement
tous pas seulement dans la situation
sanitaire que vous connaissez nous avons
déjà eu un délai pour ce rapport un bien
plus important mais en effet je
comprends cette frustration et ça veut
dire aussi que tout cela doit être
amélioré le porter à connaissance doit
être clairement renforcé sur votre
première question quels sont les
estimations mettre en place je pense que
la cnam n'avait pôle emploi aux
questions estimé deux choses qui le
montant brut de la fraude détectée ou
pas et le montant des prestations qui
sont inversés de manière définitive à
tort en distinguant donc possible les
fraudes et les erreurs je suis moi même
une zone grise possible mais il faut
qu'on ne les distingue
à l'issue de l'enquêté la cour pôle
emploi s'est engagé à procéder à une
estimation périodique du montant brut de
la fraude en capitalisant la méthode
utilisée par une présentation portant
sur les prestations versées en 2012 pour
leur part la cnam et la cnav vocation à
estimer le montant brut de la fraude et
le montant des prestations versées de
manière définitive à tort voilà de quoi
il s'agit je vais prendre le cas de
l'assurance maladie qui évidemment ne
comporte les enjeux les plus élevés
l'assurance maladie est effectué chaque
année plusieurs centaines de milliers de
contrôleurs posteriori mais ces
contrôles ne sont pas encore
suffisamment nombreux on regarde des
risques pauvres certes l'ensemble ce
taux de facturation l'assurance-maladie
fournissent une matière très riche
d'informations mais il faut aller plus
loin
ces informations pourraient être
directement utiliser où il a extrapolé
en particulier une exploitation beaucoup
plus systématique tes résultats des
contrôles pourrait permettre d'observer
ce que j'appellerais des lois
statistiques d'évolution de fréquence du
montant moyen d irréalité quels sont les
pré requis pour y parvenir nous envoyons
4 d'abord la mise en place d'un outil
informatique beaucoup plus performant de
'reporting' des contrôles effectués qui
embarque un grand nombre d'informations
relatives aux caractéristiques des
dossiers des factures contrôler ensuite
un élargissement du périmètre de
l'échantillon de factures sélectionnés
de manière aléatoire
qui permet la cnam de produire une
mesure de perte définitive du fait
d'erreurs il ya des fraudes wade erreur
troisièmement une implication de la
direction statistique de la cnam
notant qu' une différence très clair
qu'ils essaient de la cnaf est fortement
impliqué dans la quête annuelle paiement
à bon droit et fraude quatrième
préoccupe volonté de la cnam ses
autorités de tutelle de mesurer les
pertes financières liées à des erreurs
ou des fraudes le respect de l'ondam ne
saurait pas être le seul objectif
financier de l'assurance maladie le
paiement à bon droit les prestations est
tout aussi essentiel devant la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale sur la fraude aux prestations
le directeur la sécurité sociale s'est
engagé à ce que l'assurance maladie
procède à une estimation du montant de
la fraude
pour ça il faut aussi charge
supplémentaire en terme de d'emplois
mais qui n'est pas considéré nous
l'évaluons à quelques 10 ces emplois à
temps plein je crois que ce serait un
coût qui serait pleinement justifiée la
cour n'a pas pour habitude vous le savez
de proposer des créations d'emplois
publics mais là ce serait quand même
tout à fait justifiée au regard d un
gain financier que l'assurance maladie
pourrait réaliser dans la conduite de
ses activités sur votre deuxième
question quelles sont les informations
qui seraient utiles que d'aucuns sociaux
puissent consulter
vous l'avez dit la loi du 23 octobre
2008 a marqué plusieurs avancées nom
comprenant toutefois pas s'agissant de
pôle emploi pourquoi ce établissements
publics de l'état n'est toujours pas
dotée du droit de communication auprès
de tiers alors que c'est le cas pour les
caisses de sécurité sociale depuis un
longue période depuis 2008 ça prive pour
l'emploi des post-it contrôle à
résidence en france ou de détection
d'activités non déclarés par des
ministères d'allocations chômage pendant
la consultation de leurs relevés de
compte bancaire donc là je crois que
c'est une percée à faire pour répondre
de manière plus complète à votre
interrogation nous constatons que les
organismes sociaux de manière générale
ne pas encore consulté toutes les
informations qui leur seraient utiles
pour pour vérifier la stabilité de la
résidence en france des bénéficiaires
nous présentons que les organes sociaux
puissent consulter le rgi des français
l'étranger tenu par le ministère des
affaires étrangères et et les bases
élèves du ministère de l'éducation
nationale pour mettre trouver moi-même
dans cette situation est en partie cinq
ans à l'étranger
je peux vous dire qu'on ne peut pas
contrôler que c'est à titre volontaire
je me suis appliqué à moi-même non cumul
des prestations sociales
il fallait choisir mon oncle si vous
voulez je vois bien comment les choses
peuvent être améliorées très
concrètement il conviendra aussi que des
organismes sociaux puissent appréhender
sur un portail de consultation la mise à
la disposition par l'assurance-maladie
l'existence éventuelle série de soi à
l'étranger enfin il serait utile que les
organismes sociaux puissent appréhender
par leurs propres moyens
la composition du foyer du bénéficiaires
des prestations connus par leurs
homologues
quels sont les préalables juridique là
aussi j'ai commencé à les aborder
je pense que l'attribution pôle emploi
du 3 de communication nécessite des
évolutions législatives qui ai la
possibilité
monsieur le rapporteur général d'en
proposer
voilà sans doute un champ utile la mise
en place d autres possibilités
consultation que j'évoquais à l'instant
à pas les émotions beaucoup plus légère
disons de nature réglementaire
quels sont les enjeux calendaire et
informatique ce ne sont pas les moindres
nous sommes près de deux années après la
loi du 23 octobre 2018 par définition
les possibilités de consultation de
filles kovy de la base nationale des
données patrimoniales de la base des
transactions immobilières quelques
robots ne sont toujours pas entrées en
vigueur dans les faits là il ya des
développements informatiques qui sont à
réaliser sur votre troisième question
sur la dématérialisation la
dématérialisation de la gestion des
droits des prestations supprime ou
réduit certains types de fraudes je
pense par exemple à des surcharges
ordonnance médicale
on est utilisé à plusieurs reprises ou à
la falsification de bulletins de paie ou
encore d'horribles papier
mais elle peut aussi faut pas être naïf
là-dessus s'était de nouveau dès à
présent les organismes sociaux combat
des tentatives d'intrusion dans leur
système d'information à partir
d'internet il ya nouvelles possibilités
de fraude qui sont donc suscité par la
numérisation croissante des activités
des organes sociaux
nous estimons nécessaire que les animaux
sociaux aborde les risques émergents de
fraude notamment sur internet
dans le cas d'une structure transversale
à mettre en place je l'évoquais et ne
s'en tiennent pas aux risques les plus
visibles
c'est à dire aux fraudes individuel il
ya les émissions et les déclarations
erronées sur le second point notre
intégration le point de vue de la course
et qu'il ne nous semble pas que la
dématérialisation des cartes vitale en
portent obligatoirement un risque
d'accentuation des difficultés d'accès
aux soins des personnes en situation de
précarité la carte dématérialisés que le
proposons serait accessible sur un
smartphone selon un sondage effectué en
juin 2019 auprès de plus de 2200
personnes
le taux d'équipement des 18 24 ans était
proche de 100%
il descend à 44% pour les personnes de
70 ans et plus le smartphone est
maintenant devenu un objet totalement
courant sinon indispensable dans la vie
de tous les jours le risque d'exclusion
s'il existe paraître plus lié je dirais
à l'âge donc compte tenu de ces
inégalités d'équipements qui persistent
au niveau d'éducation ou de revenus cela
étant il est clair que le passage une
carte vitale dématérialisée de froid
prochaine pour probablement être
organisée par étapes pour minimiser la
gêne induite par ce changement pour une
partie des assurés et permettre aussi de
ne pas venir une meilleure coordination
des achats malgré l'augmentation rapide
du taux d'équipement en smartphones y
serait sans doute nécessaire de
conserver au moins transitoirement la
carte actuelle pour les 60 ans et plus
ou sur demande t
les assurés concernés enfin sur votre
quatrième question de manière générale
la cour préconise un renforcement des
contrôles automatisés de la conformité
ou nomenclature tarifaire des actes
facturés à l'assurance maladie par les
professionnels de santé notamment
médicaux et paramédicaux l'obligation
des paiements sept jours ne serait pas
remise en cause mais christian
d'aujourd'hui se comprennent plus de
règlements manifestement irrégulière la
cour préconise aussi que les cpam et la
faculté de suspendre les garanties
paiement pour les professionnels santé
qui ont déjà fait l'objet d'une sanction
pénale administrative ordinale pour
fraude ou pour faute
il est fréquent que les profils en
question persiste dans nos comportements
de facturations d'actes fictifs ou de
surfacturation il est utile donc que les
cpm intra- instruite par cet historique
puisse effectuer les contrôles a priori
avant de régler les professionnels
concernés
quitte à déborder de quelques jours les
7 jours ouvrés la garantie de paiement
elles le font parfois mais c'est
pratique notre sens justifié non pas de
cadre juridique et juridique et
conviendrait donc qu'elle en trouve un
voilà nos réponses à vos questions ainsi
que sur le chiffrage encore une fois
nous partageons pour regrets mais comme
quoi la cour ne fait que ce qu'elle sait
faire
le rapporteur général
[Musique]
merci donc nous allons passer aux aux
questions de politiques arrêtez monsieur
le président je crois que monsieur
brillait souhaité ajouter quelque chose
je lui ai précisé compléter propos tenus
sur la question quand on engage
chiffrage des fraudes et pourquoi la
cour ne va-t-elle pas fait je verrai
zone est aussi un peu ça a été citée par
le premier président par expérience
je vais me rapprocher du mit avec le
masque plus encore nous avons été
mandatés comme le rappelait premier
président de la cour été mandaté en 2019
pour travailler sur les estimations de
la fraude fiscale par le premier
ministre c'était le seul mandat de
confier à la cour
nous y avons travaillé pendant dix mois
nous avons essayé d'avancer de
préconiser méthodes et meilleure méthode
pour procéder à cette estimation et nous
avons essayé de passer à des travaux
pratiques
c'est à dire à essayer d'estimer selon
une méthode la fraude à la tva
ce que nous avons fait je pense que l'on
fait dans des conditions techniquement
solide il ne faut sous-estimer ni le
temps ni les moyens qu'ils ont dû être
mobilisés pour cela on a travaillé on a
mobilisé plusieurs dates analystes de la
cour vince et s'est mobilisé très
significativement kdg fip a bien avoué
accepté puisque ça a été demandé par le
gouvernement de rentrer dans cette
démarche donc c'est un an des beaucoup
de temps et de moyens pour arriver à une
estimation que nous ne renions pas qui
est solide qui est robuste qui est
intéressant mais qui porte sur un seul
impôt qui allaitent et vert donc à la
fois en termes de temps et de moyens il
faut bien voir que c'est quelque chose
qui est faisable mais qui est lourd ce
que je pense fondamentalement sur ces
sujets c'est que la réponse elle ne peut
pas venir d'un éclairage donné par une
entité externe
quelle que soit sa légitimité et sa
solidité et intervalles périodiques
ce qu'il faut c'est que les
administrations les entités elle-même se
convaincre de la nécessité de
s'organiser pour opérer elle même ses
estimations donc sion luc s'ils ne sont
pas convaincus on peut peut-être les
contraindre ça vaut pour sfr social
comme pour d'autres termes est ce que
c'est vraiment bien la réponse à ça pour
démontrer que c'est utile pour leur
propre pilotage que c'est utile pour
répondre aux questions légitimes que se
posent nos concitoyens
et puis si c'est fait par des organismes
même ça permet aussi de voir la
trajectoire de dire ça permet de voir
dans quelle mesure on progresse ou pas
dans la lutte contre la fraude est donc
ça ça suppose ce soit l'identité humaine
et non pas la cour des comptes ou
conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
tous les trois cinq dix ou quinze ans
qu'il fasse son travail
ce qui permettrait d'ailleurs également
de veiller à ce que les prestations
soient bien utilisées et d'exclure
personne parce que quand vous faites le
le contrôle de ceux qui sont
susceptibles de de fraude et vous
apercevez également dans ce que vous
contrôlez que ils auraient droit des
prestations qu'ils n'ont pas donc je
pense que en tout cas c'est l'expérience
que j'ai en tant que président de
département pendant un certain nombre
d'années qui montre qu'on arrive à cela
donc je pense que ça n'excuse pas homo
contraire ça pourrait si c'est
correctement fait bien sûr remettre dans
le circuit des personnes qui auront
droit à ces prestations et qui n'en
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui jean marie
va la nuit je rebondis sur ce que vous
avez dit monsieur le premier président
billets aussi monsieur voyez sur le fait
que ce sont aux organismes de contrôle
est ce que nous avons fait d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de limites
l'immatriculation des étrangers on l'a
fait avec le sens dia on l'a fait avec
la caf on l'a fait avec les organismes
même et ça nous a pris que quelques mois
c'est vrai qu'on est tombé dans la
période du coc vite qu'ils étaient quand
même pas très favorable ça ne nécessite
pas des mobilisations
je dirais qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
supportable compte tenu des enjeux
financiers
ils sont 1 c'est quand même des
milliards donc ce que vous avez dit j'ai
noté peut-être faut-il contraindre les
organismes a effectué annuellement et à
en rendre compte
officiellement de l'évaluation des
fraudes
donc avec des méthodes qu'ils soient
durement éprouvées comme nous l'avons
fait nous mêmes pour ce qui concerne
d'immatriculation voilà ce que pour ma
part je souhaiterais qu'on puisse sur
lequel on pourrait se mettre d'accord je
crois merci donc je vais passer la
parole à nos collègues à ce que le
rendement des g4 inscrivent nous allons
les prendre de part de catherine des
roches merci monsieur le président jean
marie l'a déjà évoqué c'est la fraude à
la carte vitale mois d'octobre ou
novembre l'an passé je me suis revue des
dates fini mouiller notre collègue avait
déposé une proposition de loi examinée
dans le cadre de des séances réservées
aux groupes et l'air sur l'instauration
d'une carte vitale biométrique
j'avais rapporté steak c'est lorsqu'on
avait étudié ce sujet plusieurs points
étaient ressorties le premier c'est que
savez certains avantages qui était celui
de de pouvoir enrôler tous les nouveaux
on repart un renouvellement total des
cartes d'avoir un enrôlement complet et
donc de revenir aux chiffres exacts mais
aussi des bémols notamment celui d'une
adhésion plutôt mitigé des
professionnels de santé pour faire ce
contrôle biométrique est le deuxième
point était aussi que le coût généré
était très élevé au regard de la fraude
estimée et les chiffres que l'on nous
avait donné à ce moment là donc on la
commission et sur ma proposition est
celle des collègues étaient plutôt
partie sur une expérimentation dans
quelques caisses d'une carte biométrique
en parallèle de la carte dématérialisés
que vous avez bloqué et qui est
actuellement en cours d'expérimentation
donc ma question elle est sur cette
carte dématérialisée vous l'avez dit
certes une pratique de plus en plus
courant que celle de l' usage d'un
smartphone par les jeunes eux-mêmes par
les personnes un peu plus âgé néanmoins
l'expérimentation vous allez me
confirmer lé sur une base de volontariat
donc on peut penser que ceux qui veulent
frauder vont pas forcément être
volontaire pour accéder à cet outil est
donc je voulais savoir quel était votre
regard par rapport à ces dispositions
différentes mais qui recherchent le même
but et l'autre point était dans la
fraude des praticiens des professionnels
de santé qui ils font soit des actes
fictifs ou ou sur facture mais aussi
certains qui sont complices entre
guillemets de l'usaj par quelqu'un qu'il
voit qui manifestement n'est pas le
détenteur de la carte et qui continue
néanmoins à prescrire ce ne doit pas
être facile à détecter à chiffrer mais
je voulais savoir si c'est quelque chose
que vous avez envisagé
merci laurence cohen oui merci monsieur
le président depuis plusieurs années la
branche recouvrement de la sécurité
sociale qui assure le fonctionnement le
financement notre modèle social français
a connu une réduction de ses effectifs
est hélas là dans la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion 2018 2022
on note encore une baisse de
fonctionnement de 5 % par an et la
suppression de 480 équivalents temps
plein
l'aquos malgré la dématérialisation est
donc privée privée de moyens suffisants
pour lutter contre les fraudes et
notamment je pense au travail illégal
est ce que vous ne pensez pas monsieur
le premier président qu'il faut mettre
un coup d'arrêt à ces politiques de
restrictions et notamment donc de moyens
humains il m'a semblé que vous aviez dit
d'ailleurs qu'il fallait changer de
logiciel est ce que c'est ce que vous
entendiez par changer de logique
logiciel ma deuxième question
c'est sur la fraude des entreprises au
chômage partiel la cour des comptes at
elle mesuré donc de manière on va dire
précise 7,7 frotte et dans comment
dirais-je
et comment est-ce qu'on peut combattre
ce travail qui prive notre système de
protection sociale de plusieurs
milliards
ma troisième la troisième question c'est
sur le travail dissimulé
les remontées de terrain que nous
pouvons avoir en tant que parlementaire
laisse apparaître que le confinement
aurait favorisé cette cette pratique est
ce que vous avez pu constater voir
chiffres et qu'effectivement pendant le
confinement il y avait eu un
accroissement de ses pratiques et dans
le même esprit je souhaiterais savoir si
la cour possède des éléments chiffrés
sur les manoeuvres d'évitement des
entreprises agricoles
selon la mutualité sociale agricole ces
pratiques entraînerait une perte de plus
de 500 millions d'euros pour le régime
agricole chaque année enfin une remarque
monsieur le premier président votre
prestation prouve que vous êtes vraiment
déterminés c'est une bonne chose et nous
n'en doutions pas à lutter contre la
fraude
et l'année dernière la cour des comptes
avait attiré notre attention de
législateur pour que nous puissions
prévoir des outils de contrôle lors de
la conception des lois même sur la
fiscalité en tout cas pour le groupe
auquel j'appartiens le groupe crc eux
c'est ce que nous faisons chaque année
au moment de l'examen du plfss et je
voulais attirer votre attention là
dessus parce que du coup je ne doute pas
que vous allez être particulièrement
attentifs à nos amendements
je vous remercie voilà pour la première
salve de questions des réponses monsieur
le premier président remercie s'agissant
de la fraude au capital la carte puis le
thème c'est l'exemple l'objet d'une
présentation en cours de la carte
d'assurance maladie par la cnam porter
ces éléments biométriques
j'ai dit
moi même à la fois la porte elle et
limite les risques que cela pouvait
comporter je pense qu'il faut s'engager
dans la démarche mais la cour en fait un
certain nombre de suggestions pour
lisser dans le temps les effets négatifs
pour permettre aux taux d'équipement de
s'améliorer pour pour mettre
progressivement en oeuvre cette démo
n'était materi nation et c'est que tout
à fait concurrents je crois avec ce que
vous évoquez en matière
d'expérimentation sur le deuxième point
salé près de capital à des tiers ça
existe mais nous ne savons pas le
chiffre est en tout cas nous ne l'avons
pas chiffré en réponse à madame cohen
vous savez oui j'ai pas les changements
logiciels et je maintiens je pense que
nous entrons dans une période dans
laquelle dette publique sont tellement
élevés les déficits subis le sont aussi
mais il fallait répondre à la crise
telle qu'elle est que la cour des
comptes tout en restant c'est son métier
fondamental sérieusement est attentive à
la gestion des deniers publics doit
mettre l'accent désormais d'abord sur la
soutenabilité de la dette qui reste un
problème de long terme et aussi sur la
qualité la dépense publique c'est à dire
que nous n'allons pas tout c'est la
création donc le public sait gérer ce
renversement de perspective aussi
spectaculaire ce serait trop attendre de
la course ne le sait pas le faire il
sait pas son jeu philosophie en revanche
comme je les dis la répartition des
moyens la qualité de la dépense est tout
à fait essentiel et nous estimons c'est
pour ça que je me suis permis cette
petite boutade tout à l'heure en effet
quand il s'agit de lutter contre la
fraude le maintien la consolidation
voire l'accroissement des moyens
affectés
peut-être utile tout simplement parce
que les ressources qui en ressortent
sont plus élevés que les coûts qui sont
peu exposés et ça je pense est un mode
de raisonnement qui est important et
s'agissant de ce sujet la fraude ils
manifestent pour ça que j'étais amenée
notamment proposé la création disait
qu'il entend ploie c'est peut-être une
percée conceptuel pour un plus à la cour
des comptes mais nous l'assumons
collectivement comme tels parce que
je pense que c'est un sujet tout à fait
majeur pour ce qui est des autres
questions que vous posez c'est à dire
sur les ados qu'ovide ou sur les autres
outils en la matière et écoutez nous
nous ne nous n'avons pas chiffrer cela
le court travail sur le cofide n'ont pas
chiffré pour l'instant c'est trop de
cette entreprise mais non bien sûr faire
ce travail je l'étais à postériori qu
est très attaché à ce que ces prochains
rapport public annuel reportant generali
veille soit centré sur la réalité des
problèmes que connaissent les français
sur la réalité des politiques publiques
qui sont menées aujourd'hui et bien sûr
le comité central dans les unes comme
dans les autres
enfin pour ce qui est de mettre en place
des outils qui permettent d'insister sur
le contrôle dans les lois sur la
fiscalité
je crois que dans le rapport qu évoqué
raoul briet ces deux suggestions ont été
faites nous ne sommes pas législateur
nous sommes exprimés sur ce sujet là
puisque nous nous même proposé madame la
sénatrice que ce soit une mauvaise idée
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
avoue initiateurs de choisir dans quel
contexte quel moment quelle façon le
faire nous ne vous par vitré cela m'est
assez on peut faire confiance
laurence cohen qui a de la suite dans
les idées dans ce domaine la comlot
nombreux parmi nous élisabeth doineau
maintenant merci monsieur le président
je voudrais tout d'abord adressé des
remerciements à la cour des comptes et
en tout premier lieu bien sûr à son
premier président et à ceux qui ont mené
cette enquête
en réalité je suis assez d'accord avec
vos propos introductif monsieur le
premier président quand vous dites c'est
effectivement des dommages financiers
mais c'est avant tout aussi un coup de
griffe dans l'atteinte au pacte
républicain parce que c'est un équilibre
que nous recherchons tous lorsque nous
sommes politique c'est effectivement de
mener des politiques mais qui puisse
être con
prise par tous accepté par tous et quand
on est sur la question des fraudes et
bien effectivement c'est ouvert à tous
les fantasmes et je comprends la
frustration de mes collègues mais moi je
comprends votre prudence sur la non
production de chiffres je pense
qu'effectivement il faut pas courir
courir
enfin faire courir des bruits qui
s'amplifie et notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
je pense que à l'issue de cette
présentation
je lirai effectivement dans sa globalité
votre votre rapport qui nous est parvenu
assez tardivement je dois dire on a eu
peu de temps pour l'appréhender mais
j'espère que un bon nombre de français
qui sont intéressés par ce sujet et qui
finalement en parle sans vraiment le
connaître et bien prendront le temps de
le lire vous vous préconisez de passer
d'un contrôle a posteriori un contrôle a
priori pour tarir les risques de fraude
mais est ce que finalement il faut pas
non plus penser à ne pas alourdir la
démarche des usagers et maintenir quand
même une certaine rapidité satisfaisante
de délivrance de la prestation
telle est ma première question ensuite
vous indiquer que seule la branche
famille procède à une estimation de la
fraude aux prestations contrairement à
l'assurance maladie à la branche
vieillesse ou encore à pôle emploi
à combien évaluez-vous le coût de la
mise en oeuvre d'une estimation
rigoureuse couvrant l'ensemble des
organismes sociaux
est ce que vous avez pu en tout cas
l'évaluer ne faudrait-il pas mener une
enquête systématique sur les motivations
invoquées par les fraudeurs la troisième
question afin de lutter contre la fraude
vous préconisez de recourir largement
aux outils informatiques et moi je suis
aussi très sensible au fait que la
dématérialisation devrait également
s'opérer auprès des assurés
mais comment envisagez-vous
l'accompagnement des assurés et des
professionnels dans cette vaste réforme
parce que la difficulté c'est d'observer
effectivement que la population la plus
fragile la personne la population la
plus âgée notamment vous l'avez dit sur
les les comment les supports numériques
peut être vraiment très à l'écart et
comment pourrait-on évaluer cet
accompagnement
et puis une dernière question qui est en
lien avec un rapport que notre
rapporteur général a mené sur le revenu
éventuelle de universel et je me disais
est ce que le fait d'adopter un revenu
universel ne nous permettrait pas
finalement d'éviter un certain nombre de
fraudes
c'est la dernière question en termes de
conclusion merci monsieur le premier
président merci pour ces questions
victoire je sma merci beaucoup monsieur
le président oui j'ai trois questions la
première c'est surtout pour parler des
travailleurs indépendants ceux qui ont
été victimes par le biais reste mais de
les compatibilités des différents
logiciels et bien ces personnes ont eu à
déplorer des conséquences graves qui ont
permis de fermer leur entreprise ils
n'ont pas eu droit aux rebonds tout
simplement parce que qu'ils ont payé
plusieurs fois les mêmes choses parce
que les différents logiciels n'était pas
forcément compatibles et au niveau
fiscal et social
ils ont eu des conséquences très graves
irréversible même pour les très petites
entreprises
la deuxième concerne vous n'avez pas
évoqué peut-être que si elles sont des
cas mineurs mais ce sont des cas qui
existent la relation avec l'état civil
logiquement cas de décès l'état civil
doit de lui et de décès doit transmettre
au lieu de naissance des mentions qui
doivent figurer sur les numéros de
licence des personnes concernées et
malheureusement ça ne se fait pas
systématiquement
donc j'ai eu un cas récemment ou
quelqu'un qui est décédé depuis plus de
15 ans et bien n'était pas mentionné ce
sont aussi les registres de naissance
donc les prestations de fait sont
probablement encore versé
et là je crois qu'il faut c'est une des
pistes oublie rappelle à faire en tout
cas pour les différents états civils
donc les différentes mairies la dernière
chance et les bases de données moi en
fait le site là c'est plus une
suggestion parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'il ya de nombreuses bases de données
et avec l'obsolescence programmée toutes
les données ne sont pas forcément
répertoriés en tout cas il n'y a pas un
maillage en fonction des différents
services où l'avait évoqué par exemple
avec la dg philippe la cnam il ya un
certain nombre de données et maintenant
avec les bailleurs donc se croit qu'il
faudrait qu'il y a des bases de données
des croisements de données même qui
permettait à tout moment de pouvoir
récupérer d'autant plus que de plus en
plus il y a on l'a constaté et c'est un
vrai problème
les problèmes d'usurpation d'identité il
y a des vraies fausses personnes qui
existent sur le territoire et j'ai un
exemple flagrant à marie galante
dans l'archipel la guadeloupe où il ya
quelqu'un qui existent et qui a une
usurpation et il est privé de ses doigts
parce que quelqu'un d'autre bénéficient
de tous ses droits
la justice a été alerté il ya eu les
décisions de prises
mais suite à un appel et bien cette
personne est encore privé de ses droits
tout simplement pour vous dire que il ya
encore beaucoup à faire mais je félicite
le travail que vous avez déjà fait parce
que ce n'est pas évident et ça porte un
sérieux préjudice à l'ensemble du
système et la dernière préconisations
que je pourrais faire c'est
l'utilisation de l'identifiant permanent
des patients dans certains cas parce que
là il a été évoqué par ma collègue
madame de roche et pour les
professionnels les problèmes qui sont
liées justement à des dérives des
dérives
donc est-ce qu'on ne pouvait pas prouver
enfin là je ne sais pas parce que le
super professionnel dans le domaine là
mais mettre en lien les nomenclatures
avec la sécurité sociale pour pouvoir
identifier très tôt que je sais pas
quelles possibilités y aurait en tout
cas en fonction des soins qui sont fait
donc identifier les nomenclatures pour
que très tôt ces personnes soient elles
mêmes identifiées en pleine dérive
merci beaucoup merci pour ces questions
monsieur le premier président
je reçois les remerciements mais je
crois qu'ils s'adressent d'abord avant
tout aux équipes qui ont travaillé je
suis le premier président de la cour des
comptes
arrivé récemment c'est un travail qui
est inscrit dans la profondeur ce sont
les équipes de la cour et qui mérite les
remerciements
bien sûr avant toute chose je sais que
vous avez reçu le rapport tardivement ce
sont vos procédures comme les nôtres
c'est la façon dont fonctionnent nos
relations mais je pense à un rapport qui
mérite la lecture n'est pas il n'est pas
un flat ma bhl n'est pas livrée à une
seule séance d'échangés entre nous il
est durable
ce que je souhaite c'est que ces
recommandations justement dans ce débat
pts en général a justement souligné
il fantasme l'utilisation le caractère
polémique peugeot allant parfois jusqu à
le dire des manipulations il faut
s'accrocher à des données qui sont
rationnels étayé c'est ce que la cour
tente de faire et ses recommandations
je pense vraiment qu'elle qu'elle mérite
d'autant plus
la tension qu'elle recoupe certain
nombre de soi qui sont faits notamment
dernière suggestion de madame jasmin
c'est précisément ce que recommande
notre rapport précisément une des
préconisations du rapport en question
pour ce qui est des questions de madame
doisneau il ya une question sur sur les
coûts 1 d'abord d'une estimation
on l'a exposé nous mêmes ce sont
essentiellement quelques investissements
informatiques a réalisé et c'est une
très faible investissement humain ce
sont les dix équivalents temps plein en
plus pour l'assurance maladie que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure en montrant
les préoccupations de madame cohen
pour ce qui est du revenu universel je
crois que l'assiette des ressources
resterait très complexe qui est matière
simplification de la définition des
ressources avant tout l'association des
professionnels et des visages est
toujours souhaitable
évidemment quand la question jédir
principal plus est posée c'est à dire
sur la contradiction entre la volonté de
tarir à la source ce qui crée de la
fraude et la rapidité la délivrance des
prestations pour l'usagé je crois qu'il
ya aucune forme de contradiction parce
que les contrôles qu'une vision sont
automatisées donc immédiat et
transparent pour les usagers donc
n'ayons pas le sentiment que les deux
s'opposent il s'agit pas de créer je ne
sais quels délais bureaucratiques tout à
fait inutile madame jasmin sur les
travailleurs indépendants
ça n'était plus un vrai sujet mais qui
n'était pas dans notre enquête sur les
yeux de suppression des antilles se
serait pas produit s'il devait
rapprochement automatisé systématique
avec ficoba
c'est aussi cette question est évoquée
notre rapport enfin sur l'état civil
vous citez une anomalie grave mais qui
concerne en tout un état civil municipal
qui n'est pas non plus dans le genre
notre enquête et enfin je le redis votre
dernière suggestion nous la faisons
d'autant plus notre
que nous l'avons reprise merci monsieur
le premier président n'y a pas d'autres
questions de la part de nos commissaires
donc nous allons pouvoir conclure cette
audition merci à toutes et tous
avant pardon il me faut votre
autorisation de publication sous la
forme d'un rapport d'information avec si
vous en êtes d'accord un préambule du
rapporteur général
il n'y a pas d'opposition à cette
présentation en conséquence il sera
ainsi fait
merci
et voilà pour cette audition de pierre
moscovici premier président de la cour
des comptes
il a présenté aux sénateurs une enquête
de la cour des comptes sur la fraude
sociale
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivie pour voir tous nos
programmes
n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite
une très bonne journée sur public sénat
où
[Musique]